i am chuck moore
i created fourth 45 years ago
it is still being used which is
moderately amazing
it's certainly being used by me it's the
only language i would ever consider
programming a computer in
i'm the cto of a company called green
arrays
which is a startup that's been in
business about five years so it's not
exactly a startup but we're still
looking for customers
a killer app um
investors
we have a high-speed low-power
multi-core chip
144 computers on a 5-millimeter chip
it's a remarkable little chip it's a lot
of fun to program
it has enormous
computing capability i'll
show you that in the next slide so first
i'm going to talk about fourth
and then i'm going to talk about the
fourth engine which is a computer which
runs forth very efficiently
i'll show you some fourth programming
and then
point out why how
you can program in low energy and i
recommend that
all of you keep energy in your mind when
you're writing programs
because pcs are going to be going away
smart phones are going to be embedded
embedded meaning
i embedded in your body in your ear in
your eye
and your heart and
power is going to be crucial in those
applications
if we talk about smart dust we have
untold trillions of computers floating
in the air
they aren't going to have very much
memory they are going to have very much
power
if you talk about molecular computers
that are
circulating in your bloodstream they're
going to have much power
they're going to have much memory
and they aren't going to be able to use
much energy so
keep that in mind as you move through
the next 10 years
oh let's go to the next slide all right
here's a
here's 144 computers just so that you
know what we're talking about
there are eight rows of 18 computers
and then the geometry of a chip that
turns out to be
uh square
each computer can talk to its neighbors
it's a mesh of computers
four neighbors
each computer takes one and a half
nanoseconds to execute an instruction
that means it's running at 666 mips
uh it takes four milliwatts if it's
running
flat out which is set seven
pico joules per instruction which is
small
now i'm going to be talking about energy
there's energy and there's power
power is energy per unit time power is
watts
and a watt is a joule per second so it
really doesn't matter
how long it takes to perform an
operation
an operation is going to require a
certain amount of energy
it requires energy because you have to
charge capacitances
and you have to run currents through
[Music]
resistors but energy is the key
and one of our instructions takes
roughly seven pico joules
more or less
one of these computers takes a hundred
nanowatts
if it's idle remember there's
milliwatts and microwatts and nanowatts
so it takes
very little energy just sitting there
and 144 computers
they all power up idle
the chip at reset is drawing no power
the entire chip can run 96 gifs
96 000 mips which is a lot of pcs
it only takes 550 ml watts to do that
that's half a lot
if the chip is idle at reset
15 microwatts of of
leakage current although all the
transistors are sitting there no
transistors changing state
but you still get a little bit of
leakage through the uh through the gate
this is what i mean by low power this is
the lowest power computer that i know of
a green arrays one of green arrays
customers developed a chart showing
all existing computers commercial and
experimental and we're right at the top
of the list
this is about the best you can do the
only people that can do better are those
that deal with sub
threshold logic with the high noise
margins and
this is a a good computer
the computers are numbered from zero
with their row in the column
zero to uh seven one seven
and i'll be referring to those numbers
so that is that is the
that is my motivation for talking about
these things
i wasn't paying any attention to energy
until a couple years ago when we started
realizing
that this chip is remarkably low energy
and now that we know how important it is
i can reduce the amount of energy it's
using and i will be doing that
i've been to a number of hardware
conferences
where people are talking about designing
asics
large a6s millions and millions of
transistors
and i've always considered that size and
speed were important parameters
but in the modern context there's only
three parameters that matter
power power and power
we've got to reduce the power for
portable applications
and also to reduce the energy used by
these server farms that require a
nuclear power station to run
okay here's one of the computers
uh it's 18 bits 18-bit words
for not very important reasons but it's
a very uh
happy number it lets you count up to 256
000.
it has a 64 word ram
that's not kill words that's
words you can pack four instructions per
word so each computer can execute a
that's up up to 256 instructions
that's what i mean by saying it's a
small computer
that has implications in the way you
program it
as characteristic of fourth and a fourth
computers it has two push down stacks
one which is common to all computers and
that is a stack on which you store
return addresses
for nesting subroutine calls the other
which is
pretty much unique to fourth is that you
store parameters
on it anything you read
goes on to the stack anything you write
comes off of the stack
there are three registers of interesting
there t is the top of the stack
s is the second element in the stack and
r
is the top element on the return stack
you've got
the programmer has got to be aware of
these two stacks
and manipulate them nicely
nothing is done automatically there are
three address registers
p is the program counter which is where
you are in the instruction stream
a and b are just registers there are
four communication ports to your
neighbors
up down right and left
and you can act you can read and write
to your neighbors
you can read and write all four of them
if you want to
there's a bit for each port
in the address
so that is that is the context those are
the facilities available to a programmer
here is the instruction set
there are five bit instructions we can
pack four per word
except that in the third slot
you have to add a couple zeros so in the
list of instructions those in red can be
put in slot three
and all the others can be put in any
slot
jump instructions can be in either slot
0 1 or 2
and all remaining bits in the word are
the address for the jump
i'll just briefly go through the
instructions this is a perfectly
conventional
instruction set except for a few in the
right hand column
you've got jump you've got call you've
got a
jump if zero you've got a jump if
positive
you've got a jump if the r register
is non-zero and decrement
so that's a decrementing count for uh
for next loop
the second column you've got fences and
stores fetch from register a
fetch from the address and register b or
fetch
inline in the next word in the
instruction stream
and the same equivalent stores
third column are our alu operations
we've got uh
binary operation add
and and or unary operations
two star two slash and minus the
binary operations take as input the
contents of t and s the two things on
the top of the data stack
and they return an argument nt
throwing away s so it's a it's a stack
operation
these are called zero operand
instructions
the only reason i can pack them into
five bits is that you don't have to
specify their operand
the operands are known
in the third column you've got some
stack operations you can duplicate the
top of the stack you can drop the top of
the stack you can
pop the stack from
s into from the return stack into the
data stack
vice versa you can push the data stack
onto the return stack
and then three interesting instructions
so you can store into register a
store under register b read back from
register a
and do nothing the dot is a no op
no op is essential in order to
fill in slots in a word instruction word
that you haven't used
32 instructions if you haven't memorized
them already it would only take you
another five minutes
and that's partly what i mean by saying
this is an easy computer program
now if you're familiar at all with
fourth
those are fourth words
there's a one-to-one mapping between
your source code and your machine
language
compiler is a few thousand lines of code
it doesn't optimize it merely translates
your source into the machine language
this is a different world from what i've
been hearing in the last couple days
um it may be a world that dates back to
1968 and it's not interesting to you
but again i caution that the future is
going to be different than the present
and i'm i'm happy to deal with a very
transparent very small compiler
you've got we can argue about whether
you call it a compiler or an assembler
because it really doesn't do anything
but compiler is a more impressive word
here's here's the code
here's code for one of these computers
and this is an example of color fourth
i created force in in about
1970 and i've used it ever since i call
that classic fourth
color fourth i devised in
2000 it has a number of nice features
mostly that i felt i needed a new
language for the 21st century
but one of the things it does is it
minim it reduces the amount of of
punctuation fourth has very little
punctuation
compared to say c but color forth
has almost no punctuation
instead it uses color each
[Music]
each source word in the source code each
word in the source code has a tag
that indicates its function and the
function is reflected in this
editor as color white words
are comments they're ignored
red words are being defined so the
definition of go
is the green words follow it uh
those green words are compiled
uh the yellow words are
executed at compile time they're direct
commands to
compiler or to the yes to the compiler
the gray words you see there are
inserted by the compiler
to tell you where you are in your 64
words
when we finish the definition of go
we've used one word of memory
and so your program counter is set at 0
1
in hex init
marks the end of code which is compiled
into
memory and begins the code that is
compiled
with this executed at load time
these computers have got four ports and
you can read and write
to the ports they're memory mapped
so you can also jump to them if you jump
to a port
you are waiting for your neighbor to
give you an instruction
if you jump to all four ports at the
same time
you're waiting for one of your neighbors
to give you an instruction to execute
and it is the programmer's
responsibility that only one of those
neighbors will actually provide an
instruction if you get two at the same
time you're dead
at load time at the time we're loading
this program into memory we're executing
those green words after init
up is the address of the up port it is
stored in the register a
down is the address of the down port and
it's stored in the register b
and then we jump to go so this is how
you
can initialize a computer
without actually having to execute code
from its ram
and i'll show you some more examples
it's it's very nice to be able to
tell your neighbor to do something for
you
for instance there's a hierarchy of
memory available on these computers
you can get at the data on your return
stack instantly
you can get at the data on your re i'm
sorry data on your data stack instantly
you get data from your return stack with
one instruction
pop 1.5 nanoseconds
you can read data from your ram but it
takes you
five nanoseconds to do that
you can read data from your neighbor's
ram
uh if you have written a little program
and and send it to him
he can give you sequential
data from ram without you having to give
him explicit addresses
or if you're doing an fft he can give
you scrambled data from his ram
knowing what you're going to do with it
you can have
smart memory if your neighbor doesn't
have enough memory
he can ask his neighbor i've had as many
as 10
computers chained up passing
passing data to me and i can get the
data as fast as i can handle it
you can actually use your neighbor's
stack
these stacks are circular you've got
the two registers on top of the data
stack and then eight
circular registers beneath them so if
you push things onto the stack
eventually they fall off the end if you
pop things from the stack
after the first two you're going to get
the next eight circularly you can get
you can circulate the stack indefinitely
which is useful
and i'll show an example you can do the
same with your neighbor
your neighbor can give you things off
his stack
indefinitely and you've got four
neighbors so we have lots
of memory available to you in these
small chunks of 64 words
64 words is 9 000 words of memory on
chip
now for words 18-bit words you can think
of them as 18
000 9-bit bytes if you wish
i actually use 6-bit bytes so i can get
27 000 characters
here's an example of some of the
programming and this has direct
relevance to energy
it's um
two star is a left shift left shift t
this is something that we do remarkably
often there's a lot of bit
bit blinding plus
is an ad
next is a countdown loop
if if you run out of count it
it falls through and the count is
discarded
so here's an example a four next loop
with a call to drive in the middle going
to be done ten times
the loop count is one less than the uh
number of repetitions
um oh that's confusing micronext
is another kind of loop instead of
jumping to an address
you jump to the beginning of your
current instruction word
so a micro x a micro next loop can
handle
uh can can repeat three instructions
because micro next can be in slot 3.
so the instructions can be in slot 0 1
and 2
or any combination of that if i say 416
for micronext i'm executing
an empty loop with only the micro next
instruction
i'm going to 416 times which is a
microsecond
another way of doing that would be to
put a no op in there now i have a two
instruction loop
and i execute the no off and then i
execute the micro next
and repeat indefinitely and i get in a
microsecond again
the only advantage of the second one is
i can count longer than 256 000
i can count up to a million
instruction delays so those are
basically delay loops
there's two problems with delay loops
two problems one problem they take
energy
the computer is running
and micronext doesn't take as much
energy
as some of the other instructions but
still you want to keep that in mind
of those two loops the empty loop and
the
no-op loop the first is
uses less energy
because micro next is executed
repeatedly
in the second case you alternating me
two and two instructions
no op and micro next so the instruction
decode transistors are toggling
in the first case nothing is changing in
the computer
except the count so you're much better
off with the first
construct than the second if you're
interested in energy
and having become interested in energy
that's the way i do it
i'll show you some um fetch
is fourth symbol
for uh at sign is
for symbol for a fetch operator so fetch
means
read store means right
bang means right exclamation point
those are particular symbols for
historic reasons and also because these
words are used so frequently that they
deserve a small
a small word
now the communication between neighbors
has has a handshake involved if i'm
reading
as all the computers start out doing i
raise my read line
and my neighbors can look at that if
they want
but everyone is reading so there's the
one massive collision
of 144 times four ports
um no problem
somebody will break that symmetry by
writing
when that happens when both the read and
write lines
on a communication port are high both
computers say
and take off and run
the data is transferred from my stack to
his stack when both lines are high
there's no no logic no latches
no delays
um it's it's sort of a blocking read
if if i want to read i just hang up i
just wait until
i've got something to read it takes no
energy while i'm reading while i'm
waiting
the chip is idle i mean the computer is
idle
no transistors are toggling
communication is is key
when you design an application you've
got to do two things right
write code for each of the computers
involved and then
manage their communication um
it's fun there's all kinds of nice
tricks you can play to make things work
properly
here's another another example of code
this is put into block 200.
the yellow line at the bottom
describes how it is put into 200.
this code which is a a message if you
will
will be sent eight nodes left
and three nodes down across what i call
my ether interface
it is code that pre-exists in all the
computers
and passes messages back and forth
this is a clock actually it's more than
a clock it's a
it's a it's driving a ceramic oscillator
which is like a crystal except it's
easier to drive
the word drive
is going to drive the crystal crystal is
attached between a pin
which this computer has access to and
ground
i hit it with a positive
voltage
and it it the the the pin will rise
i hit it with a negative voltage and the
pin will drop
i do that 10 times and the crystal
sees those drive signals and starts
oscillating
so i can start the crystal running
i'll show you how i do that in a minute
then having started it i don't have to
delay any longer
the drive signal was
a micro next loop and it was
pre it was pre-programmed to have the
right frequency
so that the crystal would start to
oscillate
but that drive is is running the
computer and it's using energy
actually you use energy when you put an
output on the pin
and that energy probably dominates
everything else but anyway
we go to pump i no longer have to have a
delay loop
i can look i can read the pin
and this is a blocking read
and when the pin transitions from low to
high i wake up
and do something one of the things i do
is
change the polarity of the edge i'm
interested in
so next time when the pin goes from high
to low i wake up
otherwise i'm asleep so it takes no
energy
to keep this crystal running i just wake
up and kick it and
go back to sleep
ring avoids the kicking
i can pump it and then i can let it ring
for a few times while the amplitude
gradually decreases and i can
pump it again a strategy for driving a
crystal with using minimum energy
and it it works beautifully now in the
case of initializing when i
load this code i'm initializing the
state of the
computer in this case
i have all these
dupes and overs
i'm filling the data stack with numbers
and taking advantage of the fact that
it's circular
so in drive when i do a store b
i'm storing something into the address
in register b and that address
is the address of the pin and the thing
i am storing
is already on the stack and will remain
on the stack indefinitely
so i don't have to fetch a literal
which makes the code smaller actually it
doesn't matter because the code is only
16 words long but still you like to do
it
nicely and you like to explore the
limits of how
how nice is possible
so i put these numbers on the stack in
exactly the right way
and then i can reference them in the
code without any
cost
this is a good crystal driver for
several reasons one that only uses one
pin
and pins are a limited resource we have
88 pins
on this on this chip
it is not as efficient as a
one of these little surface mount uh
crystal oscillators we're a very low
power computer
but we're not as low power as a custom
asic we're better than fpga
much better in an fpga but if you design
transistors unique to a particular
application
we can't compete we've got versatility
we can program
all kinds of things but for a dedicated
application you're better off with
custom silicon
all right optimum programming this is
not being
anything that you aren't uh you are
familiar with the key absolute
elephant in the room minimize the number
of instructions you execute
that's almost synonymous with minimize
the size of your source code
actually most of the instructions you
execute are going to be in a loop
so you minimize the size of your loop
you can do that by factoring your
application very carefully by unrolling
loops by doing all the tricks to
minimize
the number of instructions you execute
now actually in the case of these
computers you can only have 256
instructions so you have to
minimize the total number of
instructions as well as the number that
are actually inside the loops
you want to use all the slots in the
word the slots which you don't execute
or don't use are going to be in the
right hand end of the word
they're going to contain no ops but they
are going to be executed
they're going to take energy and they're
going to take time so you don't you want
to avoid that
it is hard and perhaps impossible to use
all your slots
that's just the cost of doing business
also when you're trying to minimize
energy you want to recognize that there
is
a minute there's a floor on that you can
reduce the amount of energy
you use but eventually going to hit the
point where
there's a certain amount of work to be
done certain number of transistors to
switch
you're just going to have to swallow
that cost
the goal is not you can't reduce it and
except the last
the last line all you can do is minimize
waste
use all the slots fetches and stores
are best put early in the word in slot
zero or one
instead of late in the word because as
soon as you stop using the
address bus instruction prefetch can
take place
and fetching the next instruction word
so it's ready for you when you finish
the current instruction word
so there's a left bias to those i o
operations
then it matters where you put the code
in memory
uh a jump in slot 2 only has three
address bits
which means it can jump within a little
three
a little eight word page
you want to position your jumps where
they matter
so that you can use a slot to jump and
that just means moving things around in
memory
that means you need to be aware of where
your jumps are
and what slot they're in and the
compiler tells you that
but the best thing you can do and
actually the thing that is the most fun
is you come up with a better algorithm
whatever you think you're doing
think about it say do i really have to
do it this way
is there a different way which might be
better
better in matching the constraints that
the little computer puts upon you
that's to make it fast to make it
compact
and fit in 256 instructions the same
rules apply really
you want to minimize the number of
instructions
you want to avoid literals a literal is
a
fetch from the address and the p
register which is pointing to the next
instruction in your instruction
next word the instruction stream and you
can
store a literal there when you fetch it
the p register is incremented over the
literal and you just picked up something
in line
and when you put a number in your source
code that's what happens
um
that's certainly cheaper than making an
explicit reference to ram
but it's not as cheap as having
something already on the stack which is
why i preload the stack
with up to eight numbers that i'm going
to cycle through
dupor would give you a zero
duplicate the thing on top of the sac
exclusive wore it with itself
and you pack a zero it's a lot cheaper
than fetching a literal zero
which would require one slot for the
fetch instruction and four slots for the
literal
and itself but this only works with zero
it works a little bit with minus one but
most literals you can't
construct you have to actually pick them
up
dupoir destroys the top of the stack if
you care about the top of the stack then
you have to have a dupe dupe ore
but it's still cheaper micronext
is better than next if you can do you
can use it
a micro next is often used with shift
instructions
um if you want to shift left
10 places you can set up a four next
micro next loop it'll count down four
places and do a shift
this is slower than actually having
ten unrolling that loop and putting 10 2
stars in line
but until you get up to eight or so
shifts it's cheaper to put them in line
initialize from the port but again the
better algorithm
is the better way of making your code
small
hey timing is working out nicely
here's another page of code
this is a i call a block
and i found that this is the amount of
source code that you can
you can fit in 256 instructions
this is an impressive little piece of
code it goes into
node eight it's reading sram
or it's it's accessing sram you've got
these words read
write and read modify write which lets
you
address either randomly or sequentially
into
into off-chip ram offship ram is
absolutely essential it's only the only
way we can get a decent amount of memory
we've got a million words of
chip ram in this particular chip ram
chip
and can address it in 50 nanoseconds
there are three nodes involved in
reading ram
one node has the address bus one node
has the
data bus and one node has the control
lines
it's worth talking about but i don't
have time
now for low energy programs
first thing you have to do is be able to
measure the energy you do that with a
micro ammeter attached to the
the the input trace to your chip
such meters cost a couple thousand
dollars but they're absolutely worth the
investment
and they let you measure the things
which i'm trying to optimize
what you want is a low duty cycle you
want your computers to be sleeping
they're sleeping they're not doing any
energy if they're spinning they're
they're draining energy a 32 kilohertz
crystal will give you timing real clock
timing
without using any energy because you're
only waking up every
whatever it is 16 30 milliseconds to
do something
if you if you zero your stacks you avoid
stack thrashing whenever you read
something and put it on the stack
you're pushing the stack if the stack
all contains all zeros
you're pushing zero into what it was all
previously a zero and it's not taking
very much energy if your stack is random
you're going to be using measurably more
energy than if it's empty
same with a return stack
and there's another thing which we only
recently discovered
it matters where you put your loops
if you if your loop has a lot of address
bits changing
it's going to cost you more energy than
if it doesn't so if you're jumping
within a page
you're better off than if you're jumping
way back when
more address bits change and so it goes
they're fun to program they're
challenging to program
you have to factor in fourth and this
chip you have to factor
into these tiny computers
and
i didn't talk about wires i showed you
the code for wires you
fetch from one port right to another
port and you've programmed node to be
nothing but a wire
it just passes messages through itself
um that's you've got to do that
you are free to choose put your
your your active computers anywhere you
want to put them your i o pins
because if you aren't reading input and
writing output you aren't doing anything
and it's
a layout you've got to lay out the code
in a way that minimizes the amount of
wire nodes you have to
pass messages through and that's what i
have to say
you